- Hello, Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Charmichael.
My one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems.
I started the Mentor Me Series with a goal
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us,
people who have done amazing things,
that by spending a little
bit more time with them,
hopefully, some of their
values, their belief systems,
their way of thinking, seeps into us
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So to help you on your journey today,
we're going to learn from Robin Sharma
and some of his best
leadership motivation.
Mentor me, Robin.
And, as always, guys, if you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
with yourself, too.
Enjoy.
(uplifting music)
- I've spent so much of the
past 20 years of my life
evangelizing a message that
leadership is not about a title,
leadership is not about
the size of your office.
Leadership is not about
having formal authority.
Leadership is a mindset.
Leadership is a way of
operating through your days.
Leadership is a heartset.
Leadership is a way of being.
And I think we're now in Leadership 2.0.
The old model of leadership said
you need to have a lot of money,
or you need to be a prime
minister or a president.
You need to be a CEO
or a managing director
in order to be a dealer.
Leadership 2.0 is fundamentally different.
Leadership 2.0 simply says
if you can breathe, if you are alive,
you not only have the opportunity,
you have the responsibility
to show leadership,
not only in your work, not
only in your creativity,
not only in your impact,
not only in your influence,
but even in your personal life.
So let's get right to the first tactic
for you to be an even better leader.
Install the lead with a title mindset.
And, again, that's just
a away of thinking.
It's an approach.
So what I'm really suggesting
is no matter what you do,
no matter where you station in life is,
start thinking like a leader,
because you really have a choice
when you go out in the world every day.
You can be a victim or
you can be a leader,
but you can't do both.
And so the more you
practice showing leadership
in your work, showing
leadership with your family,
showing leadership in your community,
showing leadership in your private self.
Practice drives performance.
And the more you practice it,
the more you start to
step in to the mindset
of a leader without a title.
Our wold says that if you are a leader,
in many ways, it's about what you get.
What I'm going to suggest
to you, with deep respect,
being a leader is about what you give.
And it's a paradox,
because as you give more,
you actually receive more.
But, again, society as
sold us this methodology
and this philosophy that
if we get from the world,
if we get more income, if we
get more from our clients,
if we get more from our employees,
if get more from our sectors,
if we get more from society,
we will feel happy, we will be successful,
we will be at the top of the mountain,
we will live these epic,
awesome and fulfilling lives.
And I don't believe that's the case.
And I haven't experienced
that to be the case at all.
To me, if you give, and
you are a humble instrument
of service, everything
just falls into place.
And so what I wanted to do is really
start off by talking
about the new economy.
The old economy was an
economy of scarcity.
It was like there's
not enough in the world
so how can I get as much as
possible before it's all gone.
The new economy that we do business in
and that we live life in,
is one not of scarcity
but it's about generosity.
And I think the person
who gives the most wins.
And that's just the world
we live in right now,
whether you believe this or not.
So what I'm going to
challenge you to do is simply,
I'm going to walk you through
some insights right now.
But start thinking about this.
What if Robin is right?
The strangest paradox of leadership
is not about what I give.
is as I serve more and help more people,
I not only become more,
I actually receive more.
The first insight I want to offer to you
and I call it the 10X Value Obsession.
Just make a brain tattoo,
sort of a psychological wiring
that you practice until the point
it's unconscious and automatic,
which is this.
How can I give my customers
the 10 times the value
that they have any right to expect?
So whatever it is, whatever
product you pour into the world,
how can that product give
them 10 times the value
that they're expecting.
That dominant mindset and way of being
has colossal consequences.
You see, most people can talk the talk,
they don't walk it.
They talk the talk, "Yeah, I want to give.
"I want to wow my customers.
"I want to give great products.
"I want to give a great user experience,
"great customer service."
Maybe even to their friends.
They talk a good game,
but there's a misalignment
between their vocabulary that
they're expressing publicly
and their actual internal intent.
And when there is a
misalignment with what you say
and what you truly feel,
even if what you truly
feel is subconscious,
you don't even know it, people feel it.
So the first idea on
this 10X Value Obsession,
you really want to come from a
place where you actually feel,
"I need to be an instrument of service.
"Robin is right, I want to
be a giver versus a taker.
"I want to give these people
who put food on my table,
"that I call my customers,
10 times the value
"they have any right to expect."
And once that becomes your emotional
and your dominant way of
being, people feel it.
And it changes your behavior.
And it changes your performance.
You actually go the extra mile.
You actually start to wow.
Your products are not mediocre,
your products are masterful.
Your team is not average,
your team becomes iconic.
Why?
Because you're coming
from that deep emotional,
passionate place that is far more powerful
than the cold hard logic of,
"Let us make our numbers
"so that we satisfy our shareholders."
Number three, I call it
the three I practice,
the three I practice.
If you want to be a
better leader, understand,
and then practice these three Is.
Number one, inspiration.
The job of a leader really
is to inspire other people.
If you look at Steve Jobs,
you look at Elon Musk,
you look at Nelson Mandela,
you look at Sergey Brin of Google,
you look at a Rembrandt or a Picasso,
these people were incredibly inspired.
They not only were incredibly inspired,
they were inspirational to other people.
I mean, there's that
incredible story of Steve Jobs.
And a lot of people say Steve
Jobs wasn't a nice person.
And, yet, if you were to poll
the former employees of Apple,
they would say, "My years at
Apple, working with Steve Jobs,
"were the single best
years of my entire career."
And you say, "Why?"
And they say, "Because
he was inspirational."
I mean, when Steve Jobs was
a young man, or a young kid,
his father said, "Go out
and paint the fence."
outside of their house.
And Steve Jobs said, "No problem."
He went out and he started painting
the outside of the fence.
A few hours later, his father comes out
and says, "Steve, did
you paint the fence?"
Steve says, "I did, dad."
Steve Jobs' father inspects the fence.
And he says, "Steve, you
did a great job painting
"the outside of the fence,
but you didn't paint
"the inside of the fence."
And Steve Jobs looks up
at his father and says,
"But, dad, no one's going to
see the inside of the fence."
And his father looks at him
and says, "But, son, we will."
Now it's many decades later
and Steve Jobs is running Apple
and they're ready to launch,
or ready to develop, rather,
the first Apple Macintosh.
And he looks at his
design team and he said,
"Here's your deliverable.
"I want the outside of the
computer to look so simple
"and so elegant like a piece of art.
"But here's the real mission.
"Make the inside so beautiful
"that it'll bring tears to our eyes."
And his design team
looked at him and said,
"But, Steve, no one's
going to see the inside
"of the Apple Macintosh."
And Steve Jobs looked at his
team and said, "But we will."
That's inspiration.
I think the only title
that really matters is CIO,
Chief Inspirational Officer.
So no matter what you do,
whether you're a teacher,
or a firefighter, an
astronaut, or an entrepreneur.
Maybe you're a managing director,
maybe you're a mother or father.
Be the CIO, the Chief
Inspirational Officer,
of all you do.
The second I of the three I practice
to make you an amazing leader
is influence, influence.
You want to be so good at what you do
that you influence other people.
You want to use the words and
the language of leadership
versus victim speak.
You want to influence
people by your mindset,
by your heartset,
you want to influence by
your thinking patterns.
You want to influence
people by your productivity.
So you want to influence people
and that's the job of a leader.
And then the third I of the
third I practice, impact.
Less talk, more do.
No matter what your title is,
you know you're leading,
you know you're winning
when you are creating impact.
A lot of people in the world,
and victims love to do this,
they talk about what they're going to do.
"Here's the project I'm going to launch.
"Here's the marathon I'm going to run.
"Here's the life I'm going to craft."
But they don't execute.
Impact is about translating
your ideas to execution.
And so the fourth leadership lesson
is be deep versus be light.
Be deep.
I mean, this is a gorgeous opportunity
to build a monopoly of
mastery within your industry.
I mean, you want to be
so good at what you do
that when we watch you in action,
tears come to our eyes.
People rise to their feet and applaud you.
And how do you do that?
Well, you separate yourself
from the way most people
operate in business,
and in life.
You go deep.
We live in a world that
is really suffering
from the cult of superficiality.
Everything is fast, everything is quick,
everything is light.
Imagine you resolve today,
"I will be deep when I do work,
"when I work on a project,
"when I build a client relationship,
"when I work with a personal relationship,
"when I install a new habit."
It's not going to be light.
I'm not going to be superficial.
I'm going to go deep.
I'm going to bring rigor to my game.
Let's say you're installing a new habit,
let's say it's my famous 5:00 a.m. Club.
You start reading all the literature
on the neurobiology of early rising.
You actually read all of the books
on habit installation.
You actually find a coach, let's say,
to help you install the 5:00 a.m. routine.
You actually build out a
protocol to mark your progress.
I'm just saying, could you imagine?
Rather than going very wide in your work,
or very wide in your personal life,
you dial it in with a monomaniacal focus
to be genius level at just
a few things, that's rigor.
And rigor's really an approach.
I was in Luzern, Switzerland,
a few months ago.
And I was working on my new book.
And someone delivered some tea.
And I had asked for some fresh lemon.
And what I noticed is
whoever had sliced the lemons
took the time to de-seed the lemon wedges.
And that's really your
metaphor for this podcast.
That's what this lesson is all about,
the fourth leadership lesson.
Be deep versus be light.
It's about de-seeding the lemon wedges
on the areas of focus that
are most important to you.
Anyone can just cut the lemon
wedges and hand them to you,
but this producer had the discipline,
the bravery, the acumen,
the commitment, the devotion
to actually take the time
to de-seed the lemon wedges.
There is incredible
and indelible influence
and imprinting going on on your philosophy
and on your mind when you read a bood.
So you have a conversation with someone,
and I'm sure you've had a conversation,
maybe it's with a chef
or a great entrepreneur
or a wise human being.
And that maybe it was
just one conversation.
But that person in that
10-minute conversation,
or hour-long conversation
said something to you
that formed your philosophy
that changed the rest of your life.
Well, that's what you can get in a book.
You can have a conversation
tonight with Kanye,
you can have a conversation
the next night with Edison.
You can have a conversation
two nights from now
with Nelson Mandela.
You can read the biography
that I recently read
of Elon Musk.
You can read about Steve Jobs.
You can read about
Vincent van Gogh's life,
you can read about Martin
Luther King, Jr.'s life.
You can read about the Titans of Industry
and what they went through
and how they innovated
and how they dealt with struggles,
and how they dealt with wealth.
You can read books on productivity
from the most productive
people on the planet.
You can learn how people
who build companies
like Ikea and Red Bull, how they did it.
They took a small idea and
built it into an empire.
So what I'm suggesting to you,
with great love and respect,
as I always do in these mastery sessions.
Is reading a book is nothing
more than having a conversation
with the author.
And you can spend your evenings
or mornings or afternoons
or lunch times connecting
with the greatest minds
who have ever graced the planet.
You cannot put a price tag on that.
If you hire C-level people,
please don't be surprised
if you have a D-level company.
If you truly want an iconic business,
one that stands the
test of the generations,
one where you build what I call
a globally cherished brand.
Then you absolutely must make
it your dominant obsession
to hire and manage and retain and engage
only A-level performers.
The best leaders on the
planet grow other leaders.
So if you're not growing
leaders faster than your peers,
you're not leading, you're following.
I'm going to repat that again.
The job of the leader
is to grow more leaders.
So, yes, do your work,
yes, become more creative,
yes, innovate,
yes, optimize your personal life.
And, yet, at the same time, make the time
to develop leaders around you.
What that might look like at the office
celebrating a teammate.
At the office, that might
look like modeling mastery.
At the office it might
look like collaborating
with someone who needs some collaboration.
At home, what does
growing leaders look like?
Well, it might be mentoring your children,
exposing them to art,
giving them great books.
It might mean being a positive
force in your home life.
So the job of the leader
is to grow more leaders.
One of the things I
observe is simply this.
A lot of people are very
careless with their language.
And so if there's a huge shift.
You can either be a victim,
or youc an be a leader,
but you can't be both.
And if you look at
someone who is a victim,
a lot of their victim-hood comes down
to the words they use.
I mean, the words used
either lift up your energy.
The words you use either
make you more creative.
The words you use either allow
you to do world class things.
Or the words you use deny your talents.
The words you use could
reduce your energy.
hurt your leadership.
So you have a choice every
day, at work, and at home,
and out on the streets with strangers.
You can develop a victim vocabulary
or the language of leadership.
And in this mastery session,
I want to walk you through
some of my insights on those.
Well, words are powerful.
I mean, words have destroyed nations.
I mean, think about the great dictators,
their words of hatred,
their words of toxicity,
their words of breakdown
cause the people around them
to do sometimes incredibly
terrifying acts.
And then you look at people
like a Nelson Mandela
or a Martin Luther King,
Jr., or a Mother Theresa.
You look at the great business builders,
you look at humanitarians,
you look at a lot of the great artists.
And they were so careful with their words.
And their words lifted people up.
And that's really what great leaders do,
they use the language of leadership.
You look at a victim,
and they say things like,
"This is a problem.
"I've got a problem right here."
Or, "I'm really scared about this."
Or, "I hate that client."
Or, "I hate this work."
Or, "I'm sick of this day."
Or, "I'm exhausted.
Or "I don't like that."
Or "She never likes me."
It's literally the language of toxicity.
And the words you use
really are like a context
or a framework, or a stained glass window
on the way you see the world.
I eman, here's a game-changing insight.
You see the world not as it is.
You see the world as you are.
You see the world through a lens.
And your language forms
that lens of belief.
I mean, your lens of belief
and your personal filter
on reality is not really
a true filter on reality,
it's just a filter on
reality that has formed
as a result of all the
words you've picked up
from the moment you were born.
So when you were a little baby,
your mom and your dad
used the language that they were taught
when they were kids to use.
And if they used the
language of victimitis
and if they use the
language of victimhood.
Well, you know, you can't
do this, I hate this,
I'm tired of this, money
doesn't grow on trees.
Be ordinary.
If you're successful, you'll be hated.
All that messaging that
we pick from our parents
and the media and the world around us,
and our peers, the little kids
that we used to play
with in the playground,
or the friends that we had as teenagers.
That will either lift
us up or tear us down.
So I guess what I'm trying to say
and hopefully I'm making
the point clearly for you,
but we see the world
through this personal filter
and a lot of this personal filter
that drives our performance
and our behavior
is really constructed from
the words that we've picked up
and then the words we are taught to use.
And so the right-angle turn for your
to create exponential energy,
mindset, productivity,
creativity, results in the
world, results in your life,
comes down to, in part,
a really intelligent use
of your words.
And like I said at the beginning
of this mastery session,
most people are really
unconscious about their words.
And that's why most people are not getting
rare error results.
So what are some of the
words I encourage you
to shift from?
Well, don't talk about
what you hate to do,
talk about what you love to do.
Don't talk about problems,
talk about opportunities.
Don't talk about what makes you tired,
talk about what makes you inspired.
Don't talk about your past,
talk about your future.
Don't talk about what broke your heart,
talk about what opened your heart.
Don't talk about what dispirits you,
talk about what you are fueled by.
Don't talk about the
things within your life
that are not working.
Talk about the things in
your life that are working.
Don't talk about your pain,
talk about your pleasure.
And if I were sitting with you right now,
coaching you, I mean, I am coaching you,
and what I would encourage you to do
as soon as a finish this mastery session
is pull out your journal.
And if you're not journaling,
please start journaling,
because journaling is a
ritual you want to install
into your days.
Joan Didion said this:
"I don't know what I think
until I write it down."
Think about that.
"I don't know what I think
until I write it down."
And so in your journal
after this mastery session,
pull out a fresh page and draw a line
down the center of the page.
And write about the language of victimhood
and the language of leadership.
And start to write down
all the words yo use
and the sentences you employ that really
are, they're really victim-speak.
And then in the other column,
I want you to start writing
down the language of leadership,
the language that as of
today you will be committed
to using so that you
start to use the language
of someone who's world class.
And I've given you some examples,
but doing that exercise
will make it really clear.
And as you know clarity breeds mastery.
Bottom line is this.
You are built to be a leader.
You are not constructed to be a victim.
And once your get your words right,
you are going to start
noticing daily shifts
in your energy, your focus, your momentum,
your confidence and your output.
And when you start
getting those words right,
you start lifting your professional life,
your personal life to a
whole new level of wow.
And, guess what?
That is what you are meant to do.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video
that you're going to immediately
apply somehow to your life
or to your business.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Clark Kegley.
Clark, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and doing that
interview on your channel.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support, man,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book.
- About his new book, Your One Word.
- So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.